excusez moi je faisais de la magie donc
je peux plus d internet
oui c'est la vidéo numéro 21 de ce
calendrier de l'avent et de noël d'idées
cadeaux où je pioche parmi toutes les
choses que j'ai pour vous présenter les
choses que j'aime bien souvent des
livres des jeux et aujourd'hui on va
prendre un livre et je vais être obligé
de vous avouer quelque chose je n'ai
toujours pas vu un seul épisode de game
of thrones vraiment aucun épisode c'est
pas que je pas envie de regarder la
série devait vraiment envie de la
regarder mais j'ai pas encore pris le
temps de me mettre dedans
donc j'ai toujours en attente et il ya
quelques mois est sorti le livre
comprend game of thrones quand on n'est
pas fan et que tous nos amis leçons et
qu'on se sent exclue alors c'est un
livre de drôlerie on est plutôt dans le
domaine de l'humour mais qui est
vraiment intéressant parce que grâce à
ce bouquin j'ai pu faire croire à un
pote philippe si tu nous regardes que
j'allais vraiment vu des mauves thrones
en termes d'intérêt de culture pourquoi
pourquoi game of thrones a aussi bien
marché et ils le disent eux-mêmes dans
le livre c'est facile de faire l'analyse
d'un truc qui a marché une fois que
c'est un marché de dire pourquoi ça a
marché
en fait les recettes sont pas si simples
mais après il ya des choses très très
drôle du style des phrases à dire issus
de game of thrones avec le moment où les
dires pour faire semblant d'avoir des
références
j'aime bien ce principe doit par exemple
ils te donnent dans quelle situation tu
peux dire winter is est nommé et c'est
génial parce que cette phrase les jeux
c'est même vraiment la place est donc
plein de
deux moments mais je sais toujours pas à
quoi ça fait référence d'un film mais
quand je la dis comme le mouvement est
important ça fait rire les gens le seul
moment où ils ont crié c'est parce que
je viens de dire film olivier de série
par exemple pour te dire à quel point je
me connais bien en game of thrones
attitude donc en vrac dans le sommaire
on à l'univers la géographie la méthode
immo france la story les personnages
alors c'est un mode de jeu des 7
familles quittent eux qui te font fait
un petit panel des persos en cuisine
comment les livres de départ aussi sont
devenus les séries télé des grosses
différences entre les livres et la série
avec des spoilers à peu près partout à
dire je me suis spoliés à peu près toute
la série et après des trucs un peu plus
humoristique du genre tu sais que tu as
été épargnée par le phénomène
quand et avec un exemple vous en faire
je vous en fais un cousin fait rien
parce que on est le 21 et à un moment
donné le 21 on a le droit d'en faire un
exemple concret tu sais que tu es en
présence des fans de game of thrones
quand ils regardent des reprises du
générique
quand il dit winter is coming au moment
de ressortir sa doudoune quand il
envisage d'appeler ses enfants à ryad
carillon et sam ça tu sais qu'elle a été
épargnée donc par le phénomène game of
thrones quand tu regarde la météo sur
ton smartphone car tu as peur des
premières neiges alors que tout le monde
crie winter is coming
quand tu penses à tony stark du film
iron man alors que tu entends parler de
la famille stark ça c'est clairement mon
cas par exemple pour moi tu dit stark je
pense iron man donc je suis épargné par
game of thrones tu sais que ta est
épargnée par le phénomène game of
thrones quand tu imagines des trucs
bizarres
lorsque don au résume la série en 10 ans
c'est cette violence et coup de pub dans
un univers fantastique avec des dragons
bref c'est plutôt fun ça se lit très
bien tu apprends des trucs dans la série
que tu sais pas si tu es fan de la série
et si comme moi tu as pas vu la série tu
peux vraiment te faire passer pour un
mec qui a tout vu
après le point faible c'est que tu t'es
spoliés amorce et 404 qui fait ça au
coût de 5 euros et je me suis dit que
pour terminer un peu le le calendrier de
l'avent spécial peut-être des idées de
cadeaux de noël j'avais vous présentait
aussi des livres à moins de 5 euros ou à
5 euros
c'est vraiment le petit cadeau qui peut
demander en plus à la fin de l'année si
ça plait je vous mets le lien vers sa
dans la description toujours le lien
vers mon livre vers les places pour
l'olympia le 22 septembre 2018 n'hésite
pas je t'attends vous pouvez laïque et
la vidéo si l'homme
ap lui laisse un petit comme si tu veux
donner ton avis sur game of thrones et
oui je vous vois je tue tous en même
temps
parce que je vous aime abonnez-vous ciao
bon
[Applaudissements]
oh